ukrainian authorities say 13 people died
in airstrikes on the city of marjanets
tuesday night just 15 kilometers from
europe's largest nuclear power plant the
site at zapparija has been occupied by
russia since march and has seen shelling
2 including over the past weekend
both sides accuse each other ukraine
says russia is using the plant as a
cover to fire rockets with the potential
for a disaster far worse than the
chernobyl meltdown 36 years ago because
it's a normal it was only one unit
here you have
six units
six reactors g7 foreign ministers echoed
un concerns wednesday in a joint
statement asking russia to hand back
control of all nuclear power plants in
ukraine saying the occupation is
significantly raising the risk of a
nuclear accident or incident and
endangering the population of ukraine
neighboring states and the international
community
meanwhile far behind russian lines in
annex crimea there is no finger-pointing
about tuesday's huge explosions there
russia says it was just an ammunitions
accident at one of its airbases keeve is
saying little but reports wednesday
suggest ukrainian special forces were
behind the attack one that could mark an
important new front line in the conflict
president vladimir zelinsky didn't
reference the blasts but he did issue a
new red line saying crimea must be
returned to ukraine if the war is to end
something he has previously stopped
short of doing redmond shannon global
news london